david my first question is for you
because dewey's grown quite a bit over
the course of the franchise so what's a
quality you were happy to see him shed
or outgrow from film to film and then is
there something new about him in this
fifth film that you just found
especially fulfilling to play
well
yeah for scream four he had worked
really hard to get you know
to work uh his limp you know
sort of to come back some rehabilitation
but no he's slipped back he's kind of
life
hasn't turned out exactly the way dewey
wanted it to it's in a bit of the dumps
at the beginning of the film so
it's interesting to see the sort of
progress and
you know it was uh
it's fun like the whole journey of it i
mean through all of them
it is a strong character arc i'll leave
it there
so jack i guess the the boys does get
pretty bloody but i think tragedy girls
is your only horror film and it's kind
of brilliant so is there anything about
your experience working on that that you
found coming in handy on screen
oh yeah no tragedy girls had kind of
that meta you know quality to it where
we're kind of pointing out things you
know is definitely heavily influenced by
scream so yeah no i i took a lot of what
i learned on that movie into this um
and it was just such a just an honor to
be around you know david and courtney
and nev and to work with matt and tyler
and this this brilliant new cast it was
just like a dream come true really
for for both of you what was it like
working with a a pair of co-directors
jack i'm not sure if you've done it
before and having worked with wes on all
four films did it kind of shake up the
production style to be working with
co-directors this time around david
uh well i've worked with co-directors
before on a rom-com i did and i love it
i actually really like uh it being more
of a group discussion as opposed to just
a one-on-one thing it's just cool i mean
that way one one of the directors can
focus more on like the camera stuff one
director can come
up to you and give you notes and have a
discussion i i loved it but yeah yeah i
loved it too they were really brilliant
and
they really loved wes's films that were
inspired by wes they wanted to make him
proud when i saw ready or not i knew
they just were such talented filmmakers
such a good movie and then just meeting
them they're just great guys they love
tor they love film and they're just
really nice too so we'd have these
moments where you'd have to really sort
of talk about character and they knew
exactly what they wanted
i've always had faith in them and then
they just justified that with this movie
good good
great speaking of wes david i've heard a
lot about how wes was a director who
just really believed in his actors while
watching too many interviews about this
franchise so do you have an example of a
time on the last four films where
something was really important to you
creatively and you spoke up and he
believed in your instincts and it
improved a scene oh the first film i
directed he read the script he gave me
notes he suggested like this list of
films that i should watch
i mean he was incredibly supportive and
amazing really just i can't say enough
about how helpful he was and
yeah it's just a legend that guy
absolutely
all right speaking speaking of the past
it kind of feels like this is a somewhat
safe question to ask you david kind of
how did you feel about how tatum was
referenced in this new screen film
compared to the deleted scene from
scream four
oh god that's an insider kind of
question
oh
uh i don't know it's it's hard you know
there are certain things that i said
even in in this that didn't make the cut
but
you know
um
i don't i don't know it's dewey's sister
and
you know i always wish there was more
sort of about it but it's complicated
very understandable i thought it was
quite well done here
yeah
jack i always love asking about the
value of a good scene partner and you
share quite a few scenes with many many
very talented individuals here so
was there ever an instance where a scene
partner helped you access something in
your own character that you were either
i don't know having a tough time
reaching or didn't even know was there
oh yeah oh all the time every day you
know i don't think you're really uh
acting unless you're taking in what the
other person is doing but i think you
know most of my scenes in this movie are
with melissa barrera and i just think
she's so brilliant and
helped me in in so many ways uh like
countless ways so i'm forever grateful
to her for sure is there anything unique
about melissa's approach to her work on
set
uh well no i mean she's just she's just
brilliant she what i find really
interesting about how she works is she's
just able to i mean it's obviously a lot
of hard work and preparation but it
appears as if she just shows up and
nails it first time through
uh which is always so impressive and and
and very very cool but she's also so
willing to
take in other people's ideas and
and uh just kind of
you know she understands this is a
collaborative effort and i felt like a
real partnership with her on this movie
i love hearing that i guess i could
throw that question to you too david i
mean having worked on this character for
four films and then jumping onto a set
with a whole new ensemble here is there
anything that one of the newer members
of the cast brought out of dewey that
you even didn't realize was there
yeah i just have to i was just so
impressed by melissa and jenna and jack
and this whole
jasmine and mason and just this whole
group of incredible actors and they're
just so professional and so quick-witted
and i guess that's what i would say like
the the tempo of humor comes in a little
faster slightly different cadence so
you're gonna have to like jump on board
figure it out you try some things and
then it's like i'm the goofy dad guy but
then it doesn't work sometimes and then
you find the right nuance it always
works man it always worked with you
in the final film everything i saw works
the tone and the pacing and the back and
forth were on point
like again like i'm it's killing me
right now to not touch on any spoilers i
know secrecy is a very very big deal and
we can't reveal the killer of course but
what would you say is the biggest
extreme someone went to while on set
trying to figure out who the killer was
before you were all officially allowed
to know
the biggest extreme
i don't know i mean okay there's this
board game uh called uh secret hitler
it's an odd name but basically it's like
it's like werewolf or uh mafia or any of
those things where you're trying to
figure out you know there's one person
who is uh secretly hitler in this game
and you're trying to ask people
questions and we would play this game a
lot and it was it's a whodunit
essentially and that was
always interesting like this weird meta
aspect of the movie like we're all
trying to figure out who the
killer is and we're all uh playing a
game to figure out who you know the bad
guy is it was it was
probably the most meta movie ever made
in terms of the process of it like none
of us knew none of us knew a thing even
if we thought we knew we kind of didn't
oh oh i bet i bet many surprises that i
won't dare spoil for anybody but i will
say huge congratulations to both of you
and thank you for yet another wonderful
continuation of my favorite horror
franchise thank you thank you i love
your shirt by the way yeah
uh
studio house designs i believe it is it
is the new favorite
let me get on that thank you
you